thousands gathered on the steps
of the lincoln memorial
the anti-racism demonstration against
police brutality in the u.s was held on
the anniversary of another famous
protest
on august 28 1963 martin luther king
jr brought his non-violent civil rights
movement to the national mall it would
become one of the largest rallies to
take place in this location
it is where king gave his best-known
speech i have a dream
current activists echoed what many
historians have called one of the best
speeches of the 20th century
this dream is still alive you might have
killed the dreamer
but you can't kill the dream because
truth crushed the earth shall rise again
we gonna rise never to fall again
we gonna stand up even when our legs are
tired
we gonna make this dream come true
king's vision of racial equality remains
elusive for the millions who mourn
george floyd and other african americans
who died in u.s police custody
my brother cannot be a voice today
we have to be that voice
we have to be the change and we
have to be his legacy thank you from the
floyd family
the latest cause of outrage jacob blake
survived being shot by police but is in
hospital
according to the family lawyer he may
never walk again
57 years after martin luther king gave
his iconic speech
the people here say his dream is yet to
be realized
let's get more on this from dw stephen
simons who's in
washington stephan tell us more about
today's event what kind of people showed
up for it
people from all walks of life frankly uh
and
families this was a family event
throughout the day that was
it was not a festival but it was
very very sincere and people came there
to really
remember 57 years ago i have a dream and
the
push by dr king for legislation
legislation to equalize um
african-american lives with white lives
here in america to give them the same
rights
um and uh well is that accomplished
i think people today beg to differ who
were there and there were as you said
thousands uh and again from all walks of
life african americans latinos
um caucasian white people of course
everybody who had an
interest in exactly the same push and
that is what this event
was about to accomplish or to
work for today was legislation
legislation george floyd legislation
make police departments transparent and
eradicate structural
racism in police departments and in the
american justice
and maybe among the most prominent
people there taking part was
george floyd's family what was their
message
their message was um peace they want
peaceful demonstrations they want
um people to be outraged and rightfully
so
um and they want peaceful demonstrations
looting nobody needs that the floyd's
always maintained this
that looting and torching properties
and so on is not the way to push this
forward again their
their main goal here is legislation in
the senate
the house already discussed
and decided on george floyd legislation
it's called like that and now this it's
the senate's term and this is what they
were
all here for today specifically the
floyds
there's been so much unrest in the
united states most recently in kenosha
wisconsin
you were there police shot in the back
an unarmed black man just days ago
how is this march linked to those events
this is directly connected as much as
jacob blake and the
shooting of uh jacob played seven times
in the back is connected to
george floyd uh you see the the the uh
protest there did not reach the level of
minneapolis until now there was not as
much uh
looting there was not as much torching
arson
and setting things uh ablaze but
the anger the pain is equally real
and then and then you see there's also
as you all know
and as we all know the shooting of two
protesters three protesters one
uh badly injured and two dead by a white
self-declared
militia vigilante 17 year old teenager
which brought this
kenosha protest into a different sphere
and on the next level
unfortunately stefan simons in
washington
thank you very much